OVER ANY AND ALL OF THE
DOCUMENTS.
THE THEATRICS ARE NOT NECESSARY.
WHAT WOULD YOU DO IF YOU WERE
PRESIDENT TRUMP?
WOULD YOU SUPPORT THE RELEASE OF
THIS AFFIDAVIT?
>> FIRST I DO REPRESENT THE
PRESIDENT IN VARIOUS CIVIL
MATTERS, BUT I'M NOT SPEAKING AS
A PART OF HIS CRIMINAL DEFENSE
TEAM.
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE LAWYERS
LOOKING AT HIS AFFIDAVIT TO LOOK
AT IT AND MAKE THEIR CONSIDERED
JUDGMENT AS TO WHETHER IT TELLS
A TRUE STORY.
IN MY OPINION, AS I SAID
PUBLICLY, THE WARRANT ITSELF IS
NOT WHERE THE MEAT IS.
WHERE THE MEAT IS IS THE
AFFIDAVIT THAT UNDERLIES THE
WARRANT, THAT IS WHAT THE FBI
TOLD THE MAGISTRATE JUDGE IN
ORDER TO GET THIS WARRANT.
AND THERE MAY HAVE BEEN MORE
THAN ONE AFFIDAVIT.
IT IS UNCLEAR TO ME THAT THE DOJ
IS OFFERING TO UNSEAL THOSE.
THEY DON'T USUALLY UNSEAL THOSE
UNTIL THERE'S AN INDICTMENT.
THE WARRANT MAY NOT TELL THE
ENTIRE STORY.
IT MAY NOT BE TO THE ADVANTAGE
OF THE TRUMP TEAM TO UNSEAL AT
THIS TIME.
THE WHOLE STORY NEEDS TO BE
TOLD.
THE DOJ IS STUMBLING, PLAYING
DEFENSE, TRYING TO DO THIS THE
OPPOSITE WAY IT SHOULD BE.
IN THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF
FLORIDA, THE NORMAL PROCEDURE AS
I UNDERSTAND FROM CRIMINAL
DEFENSE ATTORNEYS WHO PRACTICE
THERE, THIS CONVERSATION IS
SUPPOSED TO BE HAD BETWEEN THE
PROSECUTION AND THE TARGET OF
THE SUBPOENA IN ADVANCE.
THEN YOU GO TO THE JUDGE AND ASK
THE JUDGE AFTER THAT DISCUSSION
IS HAD HERE.
THEY FLIPPED THAT ORDER.
THEY WENT INTO COURT WITHOUT
HAVING THAT CONVERSATION FIRST,
AND THE JUDGE ORDERED THEM TO
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION.
WITHOUT SEEING IT, I CAN'T
REALLY SAY, BUT I DO KNOW IT
SEEMS LIKE THEY'RE NOT TELLING
THE WHOLE STORY HERE.
>> Brian: WHAT BROUGHT US TO
THIS MOMENT, "NEWSWEEK" SAID
THEY DID IT WITHOUT HIS
KNOWLEDGE, THAT HE DIDN'T KNOW
HE WAS GOING TO HAPPEN.
NEXT THING WE KNOW THERE'S A
PRESS CONFERENCE, LATE TO GIVE A
SEVEN-MINUTE ADDRESS WITHOUT
TAKING QUESTIONS.
WHAT'S THE DELAY?
YOU AND I COULD HAVE AD-LIBBED
THIS IN OUR SLEEP?
WHAT'S GOING ON BEHIND THE
SCENES?
>> IT LOOKED LIKE A HOSTAGE
VIDEO TO ME, BRIAN.
IT WAS BIZARRE.
FRANKLY EARLIER TODAY, YOU SAW
THE ALLIES OF THE
ADMINISTRATION, SHELDON
WHITEHOUSE SAY THIS WOULD HAVE
BEEN BELOW THE SCOPE OF MERRICK
GARLAND.
THAT'S NONSENSE.
WHEN YOU'RE RAIDING A FORMER
PRESIDENT'S HOME, UNPRECEDENTED,
IT HAD TO COME FROM THE TOP.
IT DID COME FROM THE TOP.
I THINK THAT THE DOJ IS IN
DAMAGE CONTROL MODE HERE,
BECAUSE IF IT -- WHEN I FIRST
SAW THIS NEWS, I SAID IT HAS TO
BE SOMETHING ELSE.
IT CAN'T BE ABOUT PRESIDENTIAL
RECORDS, BECAUSE IT'S FRANKLY
LUDICROUS TO GO TO THIS TYPE OF,
YOU KNOW, EXTREME TACTICS OVER
SOME 18-MONTH-OLD STEAL
DOCUMENTS THAT WHO CARES.
THIS LIBRARIAN, HEAD LIBRARIAN,
OF THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES IS UP
IN REMEMBERS A, UPSET THAT HIS
DOCUMENTS AREN'T THERE.
WHERE IS HIS UPSET ABOUT OBAMA'S
30 MILLION PAGES OF DOCUMENTS?
WHERE IS HIS UPSET ABOUT HOW
HILLARY CLINTON TREATED
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS ON HER
SERVER?
THIS IS A RIDICULOUS PREMISE FOR
AN FBI SWAT TEAM OF 30 FBI
AGENTS TO GO THROUGH FOR NINE
HOURS.
IT JUST DOESN'T ADD UP.
I STILL THINK THAT'S WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE, IS THAT THIS
RAID WAS A PRETEXT FOR A FISHING
EXPEDITION THAT'S COME UP EMPTY.
NOW THEY'RE TRYING TO CRAFT A
DIFFERENT NARRATIVE TO EXPLAIN
THEIR OUTRAGEOUS BEHAVIOR AND
THEIR UNDERMINING OF TRUST OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Brian: I DON'T THINK ANYONE
HAS TO TELL ANY VIEWER THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN PLAYING
A McGAME, BUY I CHALLENGE
ANYONE TO SAY HE HASN'T HAD A
GOOD WEEK.
ON MONDAY, THIS EGREGIOUS
ACTIVITY, BARRING THIS DOESN'T
GO A DIFFERENT DIRECTION, WHICH
I DON'T THINK IT IS, AFTER
SPEAKING TO SO MANY PEOPLE ON
HIS TEAM, HEARING THEM WORRIED
ABOUT THINGS IN THE PAST, BUT
NOT THIS.
THEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF NEW YORK,
AND THEIR THREE-YEAR
INVESTIGATION THAT PRODUCED
NOTHING.
THEN THEY MEET WITH THE AG AND
HIS COMPANIES IS GOING
EXCEEDINGLY WELL.
THIS MAY BE ONE OF THE BEST
WEEKS FOR TRUMP, WHO DID PERFECT
ON THE PRIMARIES THIS WEEK, BUT
HE SEEMS TO HAVE MOST OF THE
PRIMARY LINING UP BEHIND HIM.
YOUR FINAL THOUGHTS?
>> WELL, LOOK, IT MIGHT BE A
GOOD THING POLITICALLY, BUT I
THINK IT'S A BAD THING FOR THE
COUNTRY TO SEE THE AMERICAN
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND FBI
ACT IN THIS OUTRAGEOUS MANNER.
EVERY AMERICAN SHOULD BE AFRAID
THEY CAN DO THIS TO YOU AS WELL.
THIS IS NOT A GOOD PLACE FOR
THIS COUNTRY TO BE.
THEY NEED TO STOP.